nous avons besoin également de la
population nous avons besoin notamment
de témoignages de personnes qui ont vu
des choses parce que des personnes ont
vu ce qui s'est passé j'entends
évidemment parfaitement la peur qui peut
être celle des témoins ne souhaitant
absolument pas que leur nom leur adresse
apparaissent dans une procédure mais
nous disposons la justice dispose d'un
outil juridique cette audition sous x
l'audition autorisé à la l'anonymat
autorisée par un juge des libertés les
tensions qui permet effectivement le
recueil annoni parfaitement anonymisées
sans aucune mention ni dernier on y
dresse de la personne pour que nous
puissions avancer nous puissions obtenir
des éléments afin d'élucider ces
affaires et donc c'est une façon de
redire aussi a besoin de panneaux à ce
que la sécurité c'est l'affairé de tous
et nous avons besoin de la collaboration
des citoyens de bonne volonté pour pour
faire progresser pour avancer dans ses
enquêtes et pour absolument
nécessairement interpellé et faire
condamner ces auteurs de violence et
tentative d'assassinât